[Inaudible].
I would say for me, I don't understand how you do something halfway.
I did that through high school and doing that.
I saw the, I saw the instant consequence. You know,
there was a moment where after high school,
where my friends went on and they started going to
college and I was the guy that didn't even know that we apply.
I didn't know who was applying to college. When a job,
I thought we used to playing all this time, where were y'all going?
What was the joke to me was never a joke to anybody else.
I was the only one that the joke was being played on.
So when I thought we were hooking in or cutting class, well,
I thought we all weren't going to work.
I thought we all were or getting by and just off
opportunities. Oh, it's just me. Oh,
y'all been doing your work this whole time. Oh. Huh.
Wow.
University of university of university of,
I was the only that was going to community college and that's not to take a shot
at anybody. Who's going to community college.
Cause those colleges are available for a reason.
I was doing a that didn't have a plan because I thought that was the cool thing
to do. So I saw it not working hard. Got me.
I didn't take my sat.
I did abracadabra going down and guessing at it because I thought that's what we
all were doing because we were hooking in class to go.
I was the only day kid that did it the other way.
So that joke was on me. That to me,
that was an eye-opener man. Well, if I'm going to do something,
I should never do a halfway. And that means that if I do want to do it that way,
I shouldn't do it.
And I'm not going to do it to show what I can do at the best of my business.
Then why am I doing it? If you asked me to come and work out what you can.
I come work out and I the workout while I go work out.
Have you asked me to come see a movie? And I go to sleep.
As soon as I get in there or while I go to the movie, why don't I just say,
I want to stay home. Have you asked me to go and get up early with you?
So we can go look at these, these apartments or, or housing complexes.
And I get down there and it's got a negative attitude, but why the did I go?
What I've learned and how I operate is that you're in so much
control of yourself. That it's ridiculous.
And sometimes it's easy to put out excuses for yourself.
That makes sense to you. We all know the truth.
We all know if we're giving a hundred percent. If we're not, we all know
you tell me, go outside and pick up the dog. My wife tells me every morning,
I don't want to go out there and pick the dog, but I get up and do it.
If I go out there and I take two steps and I'm like minutes too early,
I do this later. Then that means that I'm,
I I'm already compromising an action that I said I was going
to do that. I'm not, if I sound want to do something,
I'm going to do it. If I don't say it don't expect it from me.
I never put my foot in my mouth. But what do you expect me to go do that?
I never said I would do that. That's the one power that I have.
That's the one thing that can never be taken from me.
What I say I'm going to do. I do.
And if I do do something that puts me in a position
to be scolded because my actions weren't correct.
Then I got to stand up and I got to say that too. Hey,
I said I was going to do X, Y, and Z.
I didn't do it. I got to wear that.
Hat hit me with the stupid sticker. The dummy hat schooled me,
whatever you got to do. I up,
I out loud said that I would do. And I did to that. I'm wrong.
That's the difference. That's what I'm okay with.
I'm okay with staying in the and smelling it. If I have to,
I try my best to avoid it, but I'm not perfect.
So there's ever a moment where that happens and it has to happen though.
I'm on it. But as I've gotten older, my words become more.
My bond take care of me. I want you to come talk to these kids, man. Look,
there's a group of kids with pay. I can't do that now because of the kids.
I'm tired. That's was at time where I can.
There was a time back in the day. Capital Dalton. Yay.
I forgot you can't get me on the phone. Well, why do I say I can do it?
I've learned from that. I don't, I don't play those games.
So if I say you're going to get me, you're going to get a hundred percent of me.
If I don't feel like I can, then I'm not going to say.